i'm a big energy person i believe in i'm
not a religious person you know what i
mean
i don't i don't you know believe
in i believe in i believe there's a god
but i don't believe in the religious
aspects
believe in the glow i believe it yes
right now that's my favorite movie
the last dragon i got a painting of
bruce leroy hanging over my bed but
the glow and that's another person that
i would love to meet uh barry gordy
because just to shake his hand and thank
him for giving the game that he gave in
that movie
but i believe in energy kind of let's
just use as an example to glow
like the point of that movie was
to let you know that it's already in you
you are the master
you already been the master but you just
had the whole movie was him figuring
out who he was and the journey that he
had to go through to get that
and at the end of the movie when sho
nuff was beating the [ __ ] out of him
and putting his head in the water and he
lifted him up and said who's the mast
and he looked at him and said i am
he went through all of the different
lessons that he had learned to get to
the point of having a globe but the glow
to me is just
what projects out of you and the more
you become
acceptant of the fact that you got it
the bigger it gets okay so
for me what i learned the most about
being around guys like diddy and
steve harvey and nick cannon and all
these different type of people
is that i have the type of glow
that is uh
comparable to those guys
my energy fits into a space
where giants live you know what i mean
and i'm
not there in regards to the status
aspect of it
but my energy is enough to
fit into a space where
all of this exists so it's like that's
what i felt about
walking into a room and seeing somebody
who
is like whoa you know what i mean and
on the video if you watch it then he
walked up to me and was like chico
what's going on man you change your diet
i was like whoa not only does this
[ __ ] know me
he know me well enough to know what i
used to look like yeah you know
that right there is that's the energy to
me
it's just being able to know that
because we all got big balls of energy
that's
in front of us and you ever
you ever walked into a room and somebody
it's like it's two type of people
it's people that walk into a room and
change the energy and there's people who
walk out of a room and change the energy
so you can be one of the two people you
can be one of the people who walk
into a room and the room brightens up or
you can be one of the people who leave
out of a room
and it brightens up so to know that
i'm one of the people who walk into a
room and brighten it up is one thing but
to walk into a room with
with giants and they still
smile when they see you and say what's
up when they see you that means that
you got i got the type of energy that i
need to keep curating and
feeding that to get to a point where
they are because that's what they did in
my opinion
you know i mean so that's really what i
learned the most about being able to be
in these spaces that
me and the people that i'm surrounded by
we have
a unique type and a special type of
energy man and the energy that we
project
is so big at this point
that you can share the room with people
who will
live forever you know i mean hey hot
brother and sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips